we got a lot of fan feedback from
Samantha a writer Samantha claimed she
had a low Uber rating because of her
mother that was great loved meeting her
mother do you know about this tons of
guys want to date yeah it's it's getting
yeah I mean I do want her to find
someone I said that last week and I've
said that for a long time and I also
said jokingly but kind of not I don't
really want to have to take care of her
oh believe me these guys aren't going to
take care of your mom you'll be care two
people if yeah I don't mean mean
financially she's financially stable
she's done well I mean emotionally be
there for her be with her bang her out
you know what bang her out
she clearly she's hurting for it
whackpacker ass napkin Ed threw his
napkin in the ring and uh here you go
listen to this I want The Wack Pack away
from my mother okay that is the line I
am not ready to cross he seems ma'am
this is a Smith kned and I heard you on
the radio it made me pretty hot and I'd
like to take you on a nice date on the
river and drive around if the night goes
well I could see some ass eating coming
your way what I like to do get in the
69th position and um I don't eat your
ass and then you could flip me over and
return the favor you eat my ass up yeah
there's a guy you want to go down on the
river hang out with
so [__] disgusting by the way Wolfie
spoke to Bigfoot last night and he's
super into Sam's mom too
for real Bigfoot wants or so we're
thinking of setting her up with a
Bigfoot he needs a good woman he sure
does uh hi Pitch Eric wants to date your
mother
hey what's up Howard I want to do some
math time I guess she's very brilliant
she's very smart why would you date her
you can't even come
baby that's good for Samantha's Mark
Sam wants her banged out yeah thank you
I want I do I'm not being gross she
needs a good banging and and I don't
want it to be you I don't want you to be
my daddy all right if you had to pick
one guy to be with your mother and the
only three guys in the world I Pitch
Eric ass napkin Ed
or Bigfoot who do you choose but you got
to choose one high pitch is gay well he
says no at least he's not gonna touch
your mom okay and who's the big napkin
or Bigfoot I I would choose ass napkin
over Bigfoot wow oh so you'll take the
worms over the scabies The Scabies the
smell uh Robin I'm taking the guy who
can't [__] him taking High Pitch Eric
right he'll just rub against you that's
all that's a lot to deal with and eat
that's right he'll do it it's like
trying to fall asleep at night and he'd
be recording cameos
Jay and Roddy wrote a song about Sam's
mom
[Applause]
[Music]
she had the real deal like a [__] that
she stuck in her man
yeah
those songs they just
you're moved by music like me I I like
to show you that
foreign